these marine conservationists are on the
hunt for spawning coral they're
collecting coral gametes the eggs and
sperm as part of an effort to breed and
repopulate coral around the world with
coral reefs in decline globally due to
climate change
pollution and other threats this work
could act as a stopgap shoring up
damaged reefs while carbon emissions and
global temperature rises are brought
under control these researchers are
securing special nets over the corals
it's a trap as much of the spawn as
possible then it's a race against time
to breed the coral in their lab or the
gametes are still viable they carefully
pair up specific eggs and sperm to
generate the most diverse and resilient
offspring possible the result is this a
tiny coral larvae once it finds a
suitable surface it will attach itself
and become a coral polyp luckily a
suitable surface is nearby a custom 3d
printed star-shaped plate once attached
the embryonic corals are moved to a
nursery a floating pool in the sea where
they can grow safe from predators like
starfish and sea snails when the corals
reach fingernail-sized are taken to
needy reefs by the plates of wedged into
crevices replenishing the local coral
population
the team previously tested this approach
in reefs off Mexico and in the Caribbean
Elkhorn corals planted in 2012 Nikkor a
cow was spotted spawning themselves just
four years later coral reefs remain
under Frant due to climate change with
half the globe's corals already gone
projects like this one show that it may
be possible to preserve and renew these
vibrant ecosystems but only if global
temperatures stop rising
[Music]